alors on a pas il y a un instant avec ce
fléau les enfants deviennent
véritablement accro aux écrans et je
parle pas des des enfants de 10 12 13 14
ans c'est tout petit petit petit
on parle même de d'enfants à l'âge de 2
ans qui regarde ce qu'il y a une heure
par jour les écrans on fait un petit
récap et on en parle juste après
Samuel 3 ans et demi ne parle quasiment
pas pour sa maman la consultation débute
par un questionnaire détaillé de ses
habitudes scolarité alimentation sommeil
et consommation d'écran c'est la télé
qui regarde surtout alors beaucoup c'est
quoi 5 heures 6 heures Samuel commençait
à regarder des écrans lorsqu'il avait
six mois lors du premier confinement en
mars 2020 je vois des tas d'enfants qui
sont en grande difficulté de langage
d'interaction de capacité à gérer leurs
émotions mais surtout de langage on crée
du handicap on crée des enfants qui ont
des difficultés pour parler et pour
pouvoir se socialiser et pour être
scolarisé dans de bonnes conditions
alors on est compte que les enfants de 2
ans passent en moyenne 48 minutes devant
les écrans ou la télévision et c'est
plus maintenant les tablettes d'ailleurs
que la télévision et les médecins
évidemment on recommande de ne pas le
faire à stagiaire après où il y a une
chose très honnête moi j'ai un petit
bébé enfin voilà c'est une excellente
nounou et parfois on est bien content de
nous coller devant un dessin animé donc
les conseils ne sont pas des payeurs il
y a un réseau social qui a trouvé une
malade c'est Tik Tok ça fonctionne très
très bien chez les jeunes et ils
regardent des sommes de vidéos toute la
journée sans arrêter et donc du coup au
bout de deux heures ça envoie un code à
la maman ou au papa et donc il faut ce
code pour redébloquer le portable oui
d'accord mais
je parle devant un écran
c'est quand même du tout n'est pas bon
merci beaucoup regardez pas les enfants
Baby Einstein c'est vachement bien c'est
une c'est tout un truc interactif et
vraiment c'est pour les tout-petits
c'est vraiment de six mois à 3 ans voilà
l'apprentissage du langage et ça c'est
chouette donc ça m'a sauvé bien comme
vous dites bonne soirée
[Musique]
de la peinture c'est c'est bien c'est
vrai alors on va demander à Béatrice à
la maison je pense
un peu un peu dur quand même on les
laissait regarder et je leur mettais
uniquement des choses où le papa est
italien donc où en italien ou en anglais
et en fait on a réalisé vraiment qu'il
fallait tout arrêter ils quatre ans et
demi et 7 ans et demi et vraiment on a
remarqué la différence entre quand les
semaines où ils regardaient
l'irritabilité
le sommeil
l'attention la faculté de concentration
c'est vraiment mais c'est c'est
hallucinant la réactivité c'est à dire
que vraiment le jour même on voit la la
différence donc on a maintenant tout
arrêter on a interdit on est passé un
lundi 3 ans les médecins recommandent
conseil une heure maximum une heure
maximum
qui a démontré que en fonction du lieu
où vous vivez les enfants regardent plus
ou moins la télévision donc en fait en
fonction du niveau social aussi des
parents si vous vivez par exemple dans
les Hauts-de-Seine ça a été prouvé que
le niveau social est inférieur par
exemple que si vous vivez en Bretagne
avec un niveau de pauvreté supérieur et
ben les enfants sont plus livrés à
eux-mêmes peut-être moins stimuler avec
des niveaux sociaux plus bas voilà donc
ça rentre aussi en ligne de compte je
suis d'accord avec tout ça mais il y a
quand même une certaine hypocrisie je
trouve alors évidemment donc les
médecins ont raison mais néanmoins les
enfants même petits ils doivent aussi se
familiariser avec les écrans parce
qu'ils vivront avec des écrans je suis
désolé
combat moi mon époque mes grands-parents
étaient catastrophes parce que je veux
passer mon temps à regarder Goldorak et
capitaine des études il travailleront
avec des écrans ils vivront avec un
ordinateurs ils vivront hélas ou tout ce
que vous voulez mais avec les réseaux
sociaux qui font partie de la vie
quotidienne de tas de gens alors on peut
le déplorer mais si on les emprise petit
et ce qui se font pas se retrouver
désocialiser non perdu c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il faut leur donner
c'était mieux avant on avait d'autres
choses
Dorothée on avait euh
des gens qui passent sur les écrans
c'est c'est il est il est un peu geek
voilà il est il est mordu de ça il est
hyper sensible il est un peu plus grand
il a dit ça mais ça a commencé très tôt
c'est comme ça qu'on a su qu'il était
hyper sensible il avait enfin certaines
petits défauts et donc on y a trouvé
des défauts de concentration depuis la
une autre non mais j'arrive pas à le
poste c'est quelque chose qui j'aime pas
y penser voilà
dyslexique et plein de choses comme ça
on a réussi à lui trouver par là on est
passionné de codage donc on a dit les
enfants sont souvent devant les écrans
ok tu as droit aux écrans mais tu vas en
fait faire un travail qui va être
bénéfique peut-être pour le futur donc
tu vas être de un écran parce que c'est
ce qu'ils aiment d'un écran une souris
mais ça va lui être bénéfique pour les
mathématiques pour apprendre des choses
donc peut-être que la solution aussi de
laisser des enfants dans des dessins
animés c'est de dire ta moitié dessin
animé et puis peut-être un jeu je sais
pas moi mettre un cube bleu dans la case
bleu pour développer peut-être attention
je suis c'est pour ça que je dis on a
ici
ça dépend des enfants on a vu
immédiatement on a deux enfants qui sont
complètement différents garçons filles
âge différents et on a vu vraiment tout
de suite le changement de comportement
général et c'est pour ça moi j'ai à la
base j'ai rien contre justement je
pensais comme toi
bien évidemment il faut pas que ça en
Piette sur la vie de famille moi je vois
j'avais été avant avec une jeune fille
qui avait un enfant et même quand on
déjeunait ou qu'on dîner ils regardaient
en mangeant avec une tablette
c'est bien pratique
toi tu passes beaucoup de temps devant
ton écran ou pas ton téléphone ta
tablette j'en passe comme tous les
jeunes comme tous les ados mais déjà ce
que je fais c'est que je fais déjà mes
devoirs tout ce qui est école tout ce
que j'ai à faire avant
et après quand j'ai fait tout ça je
prends le téléphone à tablette quand
j'ai vu du temps j'essaye de pas trop la
prendre non plus
ils te freinent un peu prends un bouquin
peut-être ou autre chose moi non par
exemple
oui
combien de temps la télé ou l'écran par
jour plus d'une heure quand même
ce sont des règles d'éducation que tes
parents t'ont donné et c'est bien normal
c'est de donner un cadre à ses enfants
c'est toujours pareil c'est l'extrême
moi qui me va pas c'est à dire la
privation totale je trouve pas ça génial
parce que ça va justement ça va
peut-être créer après une espèce de
différence entre les enfants parce que
les exclure quelque part ils ont tous
accès aujourd'hui plus ou moins il faut
juste réguler et leur dire moi en
semaine je peux finir juste en semaine
ils ont ils ont pas le droit d'ambiance
on sent on sent que la brune et la
blonde
on s'entend très bien par ailleurs mais
c'est vrai
[Rires]
c'est le dosage moi j'ai trois mecs
c'est trois gamers mais vraiment depuis
depuis toujours pas ils adorent ça ils
sont si je les laisse mais ils peuvent
passer mais je sais pas mais 12 heures
c'était Warcraft
catastrophiques c'est complètement
génial parce que vous rentrez dans un
monde vous construisez des trucs des
immeubles c'est fabuleux Minecraft là
c'est un univers qui est extrêmement
bien fait et qui effectivement
d'ailleurs il y a eu des études sur
Minecraft qui ont démontré que ça a
développé certaines choses
pas du tout parce que c'est un jeu en
ligne et c'est pas la vraie vie et moi
par exemple ils ont voulu apprendre à
parler en anglais parce que justement il
jouait avec des minecrafters capitaux
aux États-Unis donc ils m'ont dit
attends maman donc ils se sont mis à
jour